crossover our car Chester Yan Becker
says chromosomes are all the rage right
now so VW has introduced an all track
version of its caddy model but is the
off-road looked just for show or is it
really an all-terrain vehicle the Caddy
Alltrack is the successor the VW's caddy
cross lifestyle model all track buyers
can choose from the range of for
gasoline or seven diesel engines offered
for the regular caddy a natural gas
variant is available too unfortunately
VW's 4motion permanent all-wheel drive
system is only available as an optional
extra with the two most powerful diesel
engines with an output of 90 or 100
kilowatts respectively
we're testing the smaller all wheel
drive version VW says average fuel
consumption is 5.4 liters per 100
kilometers driven our test vehicle sells
for just over 30 one and a half thousand
euros in Germany
designed to be a lifestyle vehicle the
Caddy Alltrack looks the part with us
three elegant chrome trim strips in the
radiator grille the black plastic trim
on the wheel arches and rocker panels
underscore the off-road look practical
sliding doors on both sides of the
vehicle make for easy entry John really
likes our the rear seats they can be
folded down or moved out of the way
entirely which is probably the more
practical solutions practice the visible
behind its large tailgate the Caddy
Alltrack boasts over 3,000 litres of
cargo space as well as the passenger
version the Alltrack comes as a panel
van with optional rear wing doors the
Spartan interior is pepped up with
carbon fiber in chrome trim and there
are plenty of storage compartments in
the dash the transmission tunnel and the
door panels as well as a large shelf
under the roof but now it's time to take
the Caddy Alltrack off-road to see what
it's really made of
John says the Caddy Alltrack doesn't
have much trouble handling moderately
rough terrain thanks to its
all-wheel-drive an off-road abs and then
there's the Hill Start Assist which
means he only has to give gas and steer
the Hill Start Assist means the Caddy
Alltrack can make it up extremely steep
inclines from a standing start without
losing traction but a hill descent
control like Skoda offers for its Yeti
outdoor is it available for the all
track not even as an optional extra so
drivers have to make skillful use of the
clutch and brakes to get the caddy all
track downhill safely
Yan finds the steering quite smooth and
direct but he notes that the suspension
is rock-hard as the vehicles designed to
carry up to 709 kilos of cargo although
the Caddy Alltrack is essentially a pack
mule on wheels its combination of
independent wheel suspension at the
front and rigid rear axle works
surprisingly well here the VW passes our
axle articulation test with flying
colors
kid John says the candy all track
combines plenty of cargo and storage
space with off-road capacity so it's a
good all-rounder that's also a true
sport utility vehicle